well so what the Large Hadron Collider
is it's called the LHC more really early
its
collided together two protons so there's
underground rings 20 and underground
ring 27 kilometers in circumference and
what happens is proton beams are go
around and they are accelerated by
magnetic fields as they go around and
they go in opposite directions there are
two beams accelerated to extremely high
energy and then they collide together
and when they collide together
constituents inside the protons become
energy and that energy can turn into
particles with mass because after all
equals mc-squared
which is to say if you have a lot of
energy you can make particles that have
big mass m and so the idea is to make
particles that you wouldn't have been
able to have seen before on earth
because they're just heavier than things
that would have been accessible to us
and by looking at what those particles
are what are their properties where the
forces that apply at those scales we're
trying to understand what's happening at
shorter distances what's happening at
higher energies what are the more basic
ingredients that matter what are the
more fundamental forces and so it one
think we're trying to find is called the
Higgs particle which we talked about
earlier which is associated with
particles acquiring their Mouse but
we're also trying to answer this big
question about the Hargett problem which
might very well entail notions such as
supersymmetry which is an extension of
space time symmetry or even space-time
itself as we've discussed so in if it
turns out these extra national theories
are right there would be new particles
called kulusuk line particles particles
that have Mouse because they travel in
extra dimensions and it would be a
radical insight into the nature of a
universe Calissa was the first person
who introduced the idea of an extra
dimension of physics in 1919 and he was
trying to unify the forces that were
known then which were only gravity and
electromagnetism and he proposed an
extra dimension of space to try and he
realized I was the theory allowed an
extra dimension and he tried to work out
the consequences of the theory Klein was
the person who suggested that this extra
dimension was tiny it was rolled up
that's why we don't see it so includes
the clone particles or name